yeah
just two weeks ago fighters from the M23
armed group held this Hilltop
then Democratic Republic of Congo's
government forces fought them off it
they were bombing sake from the colonel
showed us around he told us it's from
here the 1023s fighters shelled the town
of sarke down below
most of the people here ran away but now
a few are coming back to collect crops
and take them to town
we cannot go further than here because
the rebels are not far away we used to
go up into the hills to bring cassava
and other foods but now you cannot go
there because you'll meet the rebels
Congo's Army says it's been fighting
Rwandan soldiers here under the guise of
the M23 armed group
Rwanda denies backing M23
the government forces say that they're
the ones who are now upholding the
ceasefire and the M23 is not they want
to show us some of their positions but
the recent fighting near the town of
muesto is widely reported to be between
M23 and an armed group
Congo's armies widely believed to have
supported armed groups in its fight
against M23 the Army denies it
they say they're withdrawing but they're
reinforcing in other areas m23s playing
a game and misleading Regional leaders
and the International Community
Regional leaders are sending troops
under the banner of an East African
Force
burundian soldiers arrived earlier this
month it hasn't stopped the fighting
more than 800 000 people have been
forced from their homes as M23 Advanced
over the last year
some of the people in this Camp are from
the town of mushaki which is one of the
places the M23 says it's handed over to
the burundian troopsy lease we know the
East African forces are there in mushaki
but we also know they're collaborating
with M23 whose Fighters are nearby this
is why we're refusing to go back
back up in the hills the colonel took us
to the Army's most forward position
a few hundred burundian troops are meant
to control the territory Beyond here
but he says M23 Fighters are still
hiding in houses across the valley many
people here question why the government
hasn't done more to enable its own
forces to stop M23 now they're wondering
if more foreign forces will actually
help
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera lopango
Democratic Republic of Congo